so I just want to congratulate you on
your uh TV directorial debut I guess um
can you talk about how you ended up
directing this episode of Loki sure it's
something you I'd always wanted to work
towards directing and and I've been
fortunate with a lot of the directors
I've worked with that supported me in
terms of just beyond just visual effects
and especially the rooster Brothers just
helping to design sequences I pitched
you know the crazy idea with the
carriers and Soldier just opening fire
on each other and blowing each other out
of the sky and crashing into the into
the into the into the river so it was
something they're like oh he's he's got
fun ideas so on every show it just kind
of you know amped up more and more and
they gave me the opportunity to go shoot
on Splinter unit and go shoot additional
photography on endgame and so you know
just kind of being with them I learned a
lot about story and and then working
with uh visual effects and Loki season 1
Uh Kevin rder executive producer saw how
much I would talk about story and and
why you know sequences should be put
together a certain way and he's like
well this is this guy really kind of
knows you know knows a lot about
crafting shots and sequences and and
invited me onto the onto season two well
that's amazing um I want to talk a
little bit about this episode because we
get to see Loki and Sylvie reunited
again and that's my favorite um can you
talk about the feelings these characters
are experiencing in that
and was it meant to be this big
emotional reunion or is there something
supposed to be sort of stunted there
because of their last meeting I think
what happened that the last meeting
definitely overshadowed you know I think
it led to trepidation on Loki's part and
he was definitely you know all through
the episode you know Loki saying hey we
have to find silv we have to find silv
we have to find out you know what she
knows you know part of him not he's not
saying out loud it's hey I want to see
Sylvie I want to see Sylvie I want to
see Sylvie you know and so but he goes
in you know didn't saying it's like well
she you know she pushed me through not
you know pushed me through a door so
he's he's feeling trepidacious she
doesn't know where she's at and you know
for her part I think you know she she
wants to see Loki but she's also found a
place for her on herself on the timeline
F found a place that she'd never had
because she was on the run for so long
so you've got a lot of emotions going on
and there's a scene that we wanted to
play with very little dialogue until the
end so the actors had to you know show
it you know on with their performance
and I think they both did a wonderful
job and you you kind of see you know
syby as he comes to the door Sophia
played it you know she's a little bit
like she's she's trapped and and I think
one of the things that doesn't initially
come acrossed on the first viewing but
you realize that for Loki it all just
happened he just got knocked through the
door for Sylvie she's been down on the
timeline right and that's kind of the
hair hair in this episode impli you know
helps us show the idea that time's
passed so she's gone in and you know her
hair has changed and never even
McDonald's knows her so she's built a
life and now lok's come in to you know
why why is he there does he want to like
is it a romantic thing is just trying to
track me down and so that's kind of a
lot of what feeling yeah I mean it's all
there um and this episode was written by
Eric Martin and can you talk about
collaborating with some of these fellow
creators like Martin and also if you
collaborated with uh Justin Benson and
Aaron Morehead on the series
for sure so it's something that they
they did on season one as well and then
you know with with u Kevin riter
executive producer he brought in into
season 2 and then Tom with his
experience I think with a lot of his
theater experience and his openness to
the collaboration as an executive
producer basically what we would do is
we would as the scripts were getting
closer to being finished we would all go
down to the writer room so we had you
know we're there with the writers with
Eric and the staff writers and then
Justin Aaron and caser what could
because he's buil busy building sets and
then we'd also have the cast come in you
know so you know and we would basically
and what we did is we went through
everyone's episodes so it wasn't like it
was just okay now we're doing Dan's
episode we're doing Justin Aaron's
episode we we'd all sit there and
everyone would contribute and so you
know you'd get you know Tom and then
Owen and key and Sophia and everyone
would just kind of go through the
scripts and and see it's like this is
what is this what my character to do how
can we make this better how can we can
you know push this scene a little bit
and and what we were fortunate we had
you know Tom and then owens's a writer
you Rafael's a writer we had Eric there
so everyone was able to contribute on
Amazing levels on Justin Aon right
through own films you know so we had
this amazing room where all these ideas
came from yeah I mean that's that's an
amazing collaborative process I'm glad
that that's how it went through um in
this episode there's a final fight
sequence and we see uh you know Loki
Mobius and Sylvia take on General docs
as she's trying to prove all these
timelines what challenges did you face
um with a scene with so many moving
Parts like this well I think you know
you're you're going into it you needed
to feel it has to have weight you know
and it has to feel like it's you know
they they they kind of they came in at
the end of it right they were you know a
lot of the timelines have been
disappearing while they were trying to
solve the mystery and find out where
docs was you we had a we shot at Chatham
docks outside of London we had a day so
we had to get you know a lot of the when
they first come through the portal we
had to get that scene and then we had to
do uh the fight shoot the fight
choreography that Tom learned and Sophia
learned and so we had to get through
that through the day and then do the
little tag at the end of the scene so it
was it was a busy day and it was
probably you're in London but it was
probably one of the hottest days of the
summer inside so by the end of the day
we were all we were all dragging pretty
pretty hard yeah I mean a scene I really
enjoyed in this uh episode is the scene
where we see Loki and X5 or Brad as
we'll call him and he's using his magic
on Brad and then later he's like
torturing him in that Cube I was
wondering because you have experience as
a special effects um artist do you have
did you take any of that experience into
filming these scenes that require that
type of um like post-production work
yeah I think you know we had a great
visual effects team we had Chris Townsen
as the supervisor and he supervised
Ultron and Iron Man 3 and you know
Guardians 2 so we had a really amazing
team but for myself I you know I I think
you know my by my experience I can you
know design you know things that aren't
there kind of knowing you know where
needs to be done you know and inviting
the visual effects team in but it was
something that and kind of knowing
what's hard and what's not and kind of
feeling guilty sometimes when you made
it hard but when we had uh Brad in the
time Cube you know was something that we
got him on thought it'd be fun to like
put them on a platform so we raise up
towards the end of it but it was also
something that you know unless they had
that physical interaction you know it
wasn't really going to sell so we we
worked with special effects to design
different kind of Plex walls with with
mounts on them so it wasn't it was about
as unsophisticated as you get because it
was basically a little Plex glass wall
with a handle and then grips you know
and and stunt people like pushing the
Plex into them and so the the the actual
shots you know it's great
fance is amazing but the shot is just
swamped with like people you know
standing in the shot it out later so
turned out great but it was like oh dude
sorry um you know
yeah oh my gosh I didn't realize that
that was like that he was actually being
pushed into a wall I think I guess that
gave him you know he he did he did a
nice job of pan aiming it but it was
just something we rehearsed it he's like
yeah it'd be great to like push against
this I'm like okay well we we brought
out the Plex gu like and start pushing
against it and yeah Rafael was great
that's amazing um so do you have any
highlights for filming this episode you
know just it being your first sort of
full go do you have anything that you're
going to take away with you when you go
to your next project I think definitely
what we did in pre-production with
everyone collaborating on on on the
script and on the show I think the
experience with all the actors is was
amazing and understanding you know kind
of what they you know all their
different styles and how best to kind of
give adjustments and you know and things
like that it's like it's it was truly a
wonderful experience and I find myself
very fortunate that I was able to work
with that casting gr well that's amazing
um are we going to see you do any other
projects moving forward or anything
works yeah well there's there's always
conversations there always conversations
going up on the second floor
so okay well that's exciting I hope to
see more of it I really enjoyed the
episode and um I want to thank you for
speaking with me uh just a great show
overall and I can't wait to see more
from you great thank you very
much